okay so if there are two things that i
love to talk about on this channel
it's sniper rifles
and how much valorant loves to rip off
counter strike that's right peter i'm
you and you're me
and this is a god
but before we go on
i gotta say for as much as i love to
poke fun at riots
it makes sense
counter-strike is the most successful
tax shooter of all time it's also the
most foundational so you'd be really
silly not to take most of your
inspiration from it that said there are
certain things that valerian decided not
to take from cs go
more specifically
certain offerings on the buy menu
that were left behind
and with good reason you see as much as
we praise cs goes gameplay
it does continue to have an oddly
bloated arsenal some guns are as
expensive as they are useless and others
are
really more of a meme than anything else
hey we need jwcam because i i don't care
what else happened no
no oh no
for that reason valrant made a
deliberate decision to streamline its
list of weapons there was no need for
seven smgs when two would suffice riot
was looking to make a competitive
shooter with so-called precise gunplay
that focused on agents meaning that
there wasn't a hell of a lot of room for
a taser and this is a throwback would be
ricky ricky from australia look at it he
just zaps spur out of the sky like a
lightning bolt however there is one
weapon that riot opted to take that we
do find a bit curious
i am of course talking about the
marshall valorance version of the scout
i say it's curious because there's
pretty much no other weapon in cs go
that plays a more unique and nuanced
role than the scout it's a fast and
flicky sniper that has been the ultimate
choice for players trying to flex their
ability to
well literally click on heads zywoo he's
flashed off the angle so now they get
dangerously close to him there is still
the promise in the mix and saiwoo
so what separates riots marshall from
valve scout and is one better than the
other or are they both sort of
quietly overpowered if those are the
questions you're asking yourself
then good because i think i figured it
out and i
really didn't want to put all that work
in for nothing
[Applause]
the stair ssg08
or shaft chutzen gever
you know what let's just call it the
scout for simplicity's sake the scout
has been in counter-strike since the
very beginning of the franchise and
although it had slightly different names
and slightly different looks
it's always done the same job either one
or two shots to the body depending on
armor but always one shot to the head a
weapon so crisp so clean and so skillful
it spawned one of the series most
beloved game modes scout knives and
custom servers aside the scout has
played a very important role in both the
history and evolution of counter-strike
its significance at the pro level
however was amplified tenfold with the
release of global offensive this was
largely owed to its super efficient
price tag of just seventeen hundred
dollars this made the scout the ultimate
eco choice not just for opers looking to
save up for the big green but anyone
willing to take a gamble with long range
engagements signals of bms is closed jw
realizes it oh his attack can't get the
kill with cold down in the second shot
jw not stopping oh my three with a scout
how does he do it i say gamble but it
isn't really in fact out of all the eco
choices the scout is pretty much one of
the most low risk weapons in the game a
lot of this has to do with tagging
potential sure landing a super crispy
headshot and deleting a dude from the
server is the ticket but even if you
just land tag after tag body shot after
body shot you can really thwart your
enemy's plans
does mean perfecto can take him down oh
no if this translates into a round this
balance is going to be very red-faced
another tag from the scout puts magics
on notice down to 15. all three are
fighting it's gonna be all six members
towards yard and another frag
it's working the scout alone has made
the round out of nothing simple went
down early electronic recovering a frag
and a rifle that now sits on booming
he's gone down perfecto go on perfecto
finishes it with four on top of all this
there's
just something about the scout there's a
reason there are countless videos of pug
demons dedicating their time to
perfecting their scout expertise being
able to consistently hit heads with a
scout is nothing short of a power move
and to some there is nothing more
satisfying
or disheartening a scout headshot or a
hitch up with one of the two pistols
just a one set it just feels so good you
know the opponent is gonna be frustrated
he's going to be left thinking why did
this happen to me but what about
valorance counterfeit the marshall does
it play the same role and provide the
same sensation
well for the most part
yes the two guns are extremely similar
both are two shots to the body one if
they don't have armor and one to the
head no matter the armor and i think
it's completely fair to say that the
marshall is equally satisfying like so
good against like sexual js
and with that things are looking up but
let's see that catboy let's get rossy
they're gonna be able to get a couple of
them
oh the jokes were so clean and they look
so crispy
the three minute delay later seeing
everyone start to explode with something
oh my god oh my god
when it comes to cost which in my
opinion is where the marshal really
shines it is only a mere
950 credits that's only 150 credits more
than the sheriff and you get a scope
that is a value [ __ ] buy if you ask
me now as mentioned both guns also kill
with one shot to the body when the enemy
is unarmored however in cs go it's only
one shot if it's to the stomach slash
pelvis and not to the chest which is
worth noting but the fact that both guns
are one shot of the body without armor
makes them very very deadly anti-ego
buys they were able to get some weapons
going on and of course the marshall on
breath is so cool
bargain practice for screw face when it
comes to scope and speed they're both
pretty comparable but i should note that
the scout does get two levels of
magnification making it more versatile
at longer ranges it should also be noted
that the movement speed for both guns is
very fast in comparison to the premium
sniper rifles of their respective games
but that's something we'll touch on
later because before that we need to go
through some pretty big differences
between these marked down murder sticks
you see the unscoped accuracy of the
scout is [ __ ] ludicrous for a sniper
even after the nerf in 2016 jump
scouting is pretty dangerous like you
can still do [ __ ] like this simple i
swear if you do anything ridiculous now
i am going to oh
there it is just ridiculous
no absolutely not he made me sound like
a gorilla the marshall however is pretty
much a laser beam in comparison you even
get to keep your crosshair and because
it's
that accurate from the hip
sometimes you don't even need the scope
bring us here already
most of the play and also just takes off
oh my keeper's head the pull up as
on top of that the marshall's rate of
fire is just
insane like the scouts rounds per minute
is 48 whereas the marshalls is a
whopping 90. that being said the
marshall only has 5 rounds in the
magazine with 3 reserve magazines and
the scout has 10 rounds per mag and 90
bullets in reserve
so you do need to be a bit more careful
with your shots when using the marshall
but for some players the bullets tend to
find their way
regardless
oh my god
so when it comes to which one is better
i would say the marshall yes at a glance
they do the exact same thing but the
cost rate of fire and unscoped accuracy
on the marshall cannot be understated to
further bolster our case our boy ominus
found out what players were the most
economically efficient comparing credits
spent versus damage output and it's no
surprise that some of the game's most
fiscally responsible fraggers are also
notorious marshall maniacs working not
quite going as far up as they wanted
good pick out of aspes
up against opponents with no shields to
play with here essentially has an
operator to work with and look at him
making it work left right and center
three kills make it four
all right that's how you get away with a
prime gaming flawless isn't it just
eights out the round but these are two
eco weapons from two different shooters
that despite being very similar do have
totally different economies so it feels
kind of weird to say that one is
inherently better than the other
which is why we're about to get into the
real question of the day are either of
these discount decapitators better than
their luxury counterparts
i'm serious i want to know are either of
these guns from a value standpoint
actually better than the op and now the
guy who actually knows what he's talking
about
hold on you're expecting
me to know
back to the tax shooter gun stats i
guess
the whole is the scout overpowered
conversation has been around for a while
in counter-strike and the valerian
community is seemingly swimming in
marshall one tricks and i think it's
fair to say that the hype on these two
weapons is real since at least on paper
the scout and the marshall are probably
better than the awp and the operator as
dimitri brought up before both eco
snipers shoot faster than their high
caliber older siblings especially in the
case of the marshall another piece
that's important and you'll probably
remember us bringing up in the op versus
up video is the movement speed which is
also significantly faster both scoped
and unscoped and since both of them are
always a one shot kill to the head it
should just be as simple as the faster
weapon always winning
right
well
not always you see the ops are better in
one very important aspect they both deal
a lot more damage and can one shot kill
almost anywhere on the body even through
most objects at the end of the day
clicking on heads is essentially what
both of these games revolve around if
you really think about it strats utility
all other aspects of gameplay really
just boil down to either helping you
click heads or keeping yours from being
clicked now obviously people aren't
aimbots but what if you got really
really good with the scouter marshall
well when it comes to pros at the top of
both games people got so good with these
two guns that it called into question
whether or not nerfs should be
implemented i
do think the marshall is overpowered i
think the fact that it shoots so fast
makes it just like you can just
buy it and take it into the next round
you it does so much damage like i think
i think the speed the fire rate speed on
the marshall should be like nerfed i
think and then it would be like an okay
gun so could somebody exploit the scout
if they wanted to
i mean
technically yes the closest thing we've
had to that was big searson in 2020.
that year he made up 7.7
of all scout kills amongst the top 30
teams in the world and for his trouble
it helped make him the first german to
be on the hltv top 20. it's in damn and
that's a quick demise sarasota will get
a tag which is good but it's not a kill
he'll have to reface for that and he's
successful in finding it continues to
rain fire and
not even that performance can save their
inferno right now you said with the
start of this one that a round win like
this would be telling
and you better believe big used his
proficiency to their advantage you could
give searson a scout he would get at
least a bunch of tags and the rest of
the team could finish the job with just
pistols this made big a pretty dangerous
team to face especially when they were
low on cash searson did this so often
that he netted over twice as many kills
with the scout as he did with the ak and
there is still a t retreating back from
that position they are going to try to
challenge tirson on the cross and you
can't afford to make this mistake dude
he hits that next one too this is just
ridiculous i mean you've got to flash
the guy his scout shoots magnetized
bullets or some [ __ ] because it's
uncanny what it does to these players
and he could very well
drop these next two frags on top of it
all
are you
unreal and if a team wanted to do the
same thing in valorant it could
certainly be done to at least similar
effect but with all of that being said
there is one important thing to keep in
mind most levels of both games are about
risk versus reward if you have the money
to afford the higher damage sniper it
generally isn't worth the risk of
sticking with the scout or the marshal
even the best players in the world don't
hit every shot so i guess to answer your
question dimitri sure you could
technically call the scout and the
marshall the statistically better sniper
rifles
at least
if you're an aimbot and that was the guy
who actually knows what he's talking
about just aim for the heck
alright that's easy
well i mean
it's not but i guess
that's the rub like colton mentioned if
shooting people on the head were that
simple then everyone would use the cheap
snipers even simple but it isn't which
is maybe what makes them so special
because those who can wield either of
them with expert precision
can just
do things that the rest of us can't
exchange of the head shots puts it into
a perfect position for poison it's been
sitting waiting and oh
what what is that
try to pick this guy with uh my let's go
let's see
done
falling with a scout he's a head shot
he's got it
good stuff warp does see him cross pit
side but g2 not feeling pressured to
peek they've got the advantage
and he goes for it anyway that is a
filthy flick from the feet to the face
from fallen and riot probably decided to
include their own scout for that very
reason it's fun satisfying gives way to
a little bm
and won't leave a hole in your economy
it's sort of like taco bell it's a
marshall in its tents so you don't count
it out oh my gosh you don't count it out
taco bell is a brand that believes in
living
moss
and if you really think about it both
the marshall
and the scout are truer tests of
someone's sniping ability than perhaps
the most famous gaming sniper of all
time so next time you get flamed for
holding on to your scout or marshall
during a full buy
ignore it these guns are god tier and
fully serviceable against gun rounds
as long as you know
you hit your shots
stare ssg wait or
what the [ __ ]
[Music]
please don't do anything that would make
me [ __ ] lose a take
centria i'm begging you please
it's like taco bell
is none of those things look at this one
of those things oh gives no no we got it
we got a
gives way to a little bm
[Music]
there it is there it is
there it is
there it is that's why i'm the writer
colton
this is why they pay me the big big
bucks